احلام الثراء السريع نقطه الضعف التي
يستغلها عصابات الاحتيال في مصر القصه
متكرره لكن نصاب هذه المره او المشتريح
كما يطلق عليه في مصر هو الانترنت هوك فول
هو تطبيق الكتروني انطلق في اغسطس الماضي
بغرض الاستثمار وتعدين العملات المشفره او
هما الضحاياها بالربح الفوري عن طريق
الهاتف او الكمبيوتر واغرضتهم بضخ مزيد من
الاموال من اجل ربح اكبر واسرع قيل ان
المنصه نجحت في الاستيلاء على سته مليارات
جنيه قبل اغلاق الموقع والاختفاء لكن في
بيان جديد نشرته وزاره الداخليه المصريه
عبر الانترنت جاء فيها ان المبلغ الاجمالي
يقدر بتسعه عشر مليون جنيه وان الاجهزه
الامنيه تمكنت من ضبط التشكيل العصابه
وعددهم 29 شخصا
انه كان في برنامج او منصب بتقول ان هي
بتعمل حاجه اسمها
عملات رقميه
تعدين حاجات كده
باختصار انت فلوس للمنصه دي وبتجيلك مكسب
انا رحت عملت قرض قرض رحت عملت قرض
ودفعته للمنصه دي مش بس كده مش استنى ان
انا اخد فلوسى او حتى اكسب لا انا ما
عملتش كده انا طماط طمعت اكتر انا طمعت
انا طمعت وانا استاهل وده جزائري انا
عارفه شركه وهميه للاستثمار والارباح تنصب
على عشرات المصريين ما الذي حصل تحديدا في
البدايه بدا الموقع حضرتك من
14/8/2022 في الحقيقه
اتنصب على كثير من الناس زي ما حضرتك في
التقرير كده اللي هو بتدخل حاجه اسمها اله
مثلا ب 1600 في خلال 100 يوم تاخد على
اليوم الواحد 4 دولار خير كمان سيادتك ان
المشرفين كل اما حضرتك كل اما تدخلي حد مع
حضرتك او تجيبي حد زي زي ما في التقرير
اللي تم بتاخدي على الشخص الواحد اتنين
دولار وكل اما الشريحه تعلى او الاله تعلى
تاخدي على الفرد الواحد اربعه دولار في
الحقيقه طبعا ان ان احنا لما تقدمنا بعدد
من المحاضر في مديريات الامن على مستوى
الجمهوريه باعتبار احد المحامين الممثلين
عن الضحايا والله يا فندم احنا ورد الينا
ناس كتير في ناس امبارح اول امبارح ماتت
ماتت ماتت فعلا من الصدمه ناس حاطه تشقق
عمرها ناس بعت اراضي ليها ناس مضت على
نفسها ايصالات امانه ناس باعت عربياتها
ناس بعد بيوتها طبعا ده كله علشان
الثراء السريع كل واحد فينا النهارده
بيحلم بالسراء السريع وصل عدد المشتركين
في هذه المنصه الوهميه 600,000 كانت
الارباح يوميه طبيعيه وحتى تتضاعف وصلت
مليون ما الذي حصل بعدها
اللي اشترك على على البرنامج او على
الابلكيشن حوالي 800 الف واحد تمام تم
النصب عليهم هم اللي ورد او ذكر ان هم
حوالي 500 الف ولكن هم 800 الف على حسب
السيستم اللي احنا شفناته كل واحد يا فندم
كل واحد حاول بقدر الامكان ان هو يجيب
فلوس ويستلف فلوس وفي ناس خدت كروت علشان
حضرتك ان هم يوظفوها مع الناس دي باعتبار
البرمجه واعتبار اجهزه الحاسب الالي عبد
العزيز هل قدرتوا توصلوا لهم وش العقوبه
القانونيه وهل يمكن ارجاع حقوق لتم النصب
عليهم سؤال محترم يا فندم طبعا تم الوصول
للبعض حوالي كانوا في في 2 فيلا موجودين
بيمارسوا النشاطهم الاجرامي اتمسك اكتر من
9,965 محفظه الكترونيه واكثر من 41 كارت
ده بنكي وحوالي 3000 3000 موبايل في ناس
كثير بقى بتسال هو احنا ممكن ترجع لنا
فلوس نا احنا بقدر الامكان احنا فيه
دلوقتي متهمين بالنسبه لنا وبنحاول بقدر
الامكان ان شاء الله ان احنا نوجههم كل
التهم تمام
واحنا ان شاء الله في القضاء باذن الله او
في الاجراءات القانونيه بعد كده هنطالب
بتعويضات لهم على حسب طبعا احنا منتظرين
حسب القيد الوصف يا فندم بتاع النيابه حسب
ما توصف النيابه احنا بعد كده احنا
كمحامين هنشتغل عليها
[موسيقى]